the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so let me just start out by giving you a
quick overview of what we're gonna be
doing today what the plan is
I'm gonna spend the first maybe third or
so of the time or maybe hopefully less
than that talking very generally about
basic camera concepts and if you have
some video experience or if you have
some still photography experience
they're gonna be pretty familiar to you
I'm going to keep it fairly general and
we're gonna go through fairly quickly
some basic things in order to sort of
lay the groundwork for the more exciting
and interesting part which is actually
going out and shooting so but after I
finished that then Dave is going to take
over and he's going to provide you with
a very quick introduction to our camera
where the controls are how things are
set up how to do some of the things that
I'm talking about specifically with our
camera and then we're all going to go
out and have a chance to actually shoot
some stuff which should be a lot of fun
so that's the story and I'm just gonna
jump right in what although I guess I
should ask first it does I don't have
any questions or thoughts from Wednesday
night okay well what we're trying to do
is is build every session on the last
one and so I'm going to start out by by
referencing something that I talked
about last time sort of the way that we
began which was looking at another
visual art right painting and if I asked
you what the tools and the medium of a
painter was were you would have a pretty
easy answer right I mean it's paint
it's canvas it's the stuff that you do
use to make a painting same with
sculpture
you know stone steel mud bricks whatever
it may be so the question then is what's
the medium for film and what are the
tools of
temir obvious obviously the camera
exactly that's that's kind of the brush
you know I mean not exactly but but it's
that's the basic tool but what else what
are the other tools of the filmmaker
light others
mm-hmm so the the actual what you record
on exactly and how you manipulate that
but there are lots of others as well and
a concept that I find really useful and
interesting in just thinking about kind
of what you do as a filmmaker or a video
maker and I'm gonna use those terms
interchangeably as I said on Wednesday
are what we call or a can be called the
plastic elements of film and by that I
just mean the elements that you as the
artist the filmmaker have control over
and that you can change at will so the
camera what you choose to do with the
camera is obviously extremely important
and in fact central to to the outcome
and to what you want to do as an artist
or as a documentarian lighting again
whether you're actually adding light
setting up why it's doing very complex
lighting setups or just using available
light how you choose to place your
subject in relation to the Sun how you
choose to like you know turn light the
lights in a room these fluorescent
lights above us we're taping this this
for OpenCourseWare and before everyone
came we tried a couple of different
settings for the overhead lights and so
that is again a plastic element but
there are others too can you think of
others the lens yeah what lens you use
to shoot with exactly others
yeah exactly this scene the setting
could be the location another way of
thinking about it so if you're doing and
that's obviously true of a fiction film
but it's also true of a documentary if
you're interviewing somebody where do
you choose to put them and what does
where you choose to put them say about
your subject what do you want it to say
you have control over that and you have
in a lot of ways you have as much or as
little control as you want because you
can be very interventionist and place
them exactly where you want them or you
can just sort of do whatever happens you
know if you went to interview a
professor here at MIT and you found them
in their office you just could do it
right there and that would say something
about them as well you know do you clean
the office or do you not clean the
office that's another thing so so if you
think about it like that then suddenly
this whole world of elements opens up
right props how you arrange things in a
scene or you know whether you kind of
dress the set and again whether it's a
documentary or a fiction film it's still
it still applies
sound how you record the sound whether
you record the sound what you do in
editing in order to change things if you
add music if you mix the sound if you
add sound effects and editing itself is
a plastic element that's almost as
important as the camera it's it's a
central sort of tool for the filmmaker
how you edit a piece so there are any
number and these are just a few any
number of plastic elements that you can
control and I think this is just like a
central idea that sort of seems obvious
but it's also something that you want to
continually remind yourself because I
know that in you know in my experience
as a producer or a director and doing a
lot of other things in film as well you
you can sometimes forget that you have
the ability to change things because
sometimes you're rushed you don't have
time or see something kind of you know
fate deals you a blow that
you know you sort of sort of feel you
have to accept but you just remember
that that you know you can take the
initiative and change something so you
know the location doesn't work the
beautiful idea you had is not going to
not going to happen
you improvise and think think of
something else you have the power to
change a lot of these things so today
we're gonna talk about camera which is
in many ways first and foremost the
plastic element it's the first one that
was mentioned here when I asked you
about what kinds of things you you use
as a tool and it's sort of obviously the
fundamental thing because everything is
passing through the lens and I want to
just provide a very very brief
introduction to some of the really basic
ideas in filmmaking which are very
similar in many ways to some of the
basic ideas and still photography if
you've done that and it there one way to
think about them one way I like to think
about them are as the four s f-stop or
exposure focus focal length and framing
and there are others but they don't
start with F so I like you know I like
to start with these and f-stop is also
maybe a bit simplistic when you're
talking about exposure but it's just a
way to remember them f-stop focus focal
length framing and I'm just going to
spend a couple of minutes on each one
and don't expect to sort of absorb it
all right now it's the kind of thing
that's gonna make a lot more sense when
you're filming so I'm not going to get
really hung up on a lot of details this
isn't a class on optics or the physics
of light or anything like that but I
want to just introduce a couple of terms
so first exposure f-stop or aperture is
one of the basic things that controls
you know what your exposure of your
camera is and that is basically in
simplistic terms or so in simple terms
how much light is entering the camera
lens how much light is hitting the
sensor that's recording the image and
lenses are equipped with an aperture
that is adjustable so you see at the top
there there's an aperture that's very
wide it's very open which in terms of
f-stop is a very low number
and at the bottom that very same lens
the aperture is almost completely shut
it's just almost a pinhole and that
corresponds to a very high F number F
f-22 and lenses you'll see that the
lenses on our cameras can be adjusted
you can either adjust leave it in auto
and let the camera choose what the
exposure should be or you can choose it
and obviously the more light you have in
a scene the more stop down or the
smaller the aperture would be in order
to get the correct exposure in other
words in order to have enough light
hitting your sensor but not too much
light in order to get a good a good
looking image just just also quickly
f-stop is not the only way to adjust
exposure you do have other controls you
have the shutter speed the shutter speed
is basically determining how much time
each frame of your video or your film is
exposed to light as it goes by and you
can adjust it but in video and film you
normally aren't going to adjust it you
normally want to keep it for a sort of
normal appearing motion at about one
sixtieth of a second so in practical
terms unless you're shooting something
that's a very high-speed activity or or
some kind of special situation or you're
maybe in a very very low light situation
you don't want to use the shutter as an
exposure of control mainly you're gonna
keep it at 160 yes sir it's usually
double the frame rate so if it's like if
you're shooting 24 frames per second it
would be 1 over 48 like you know right
record and we're shooting 30 frames a
second so that's why it's 61 60 yeah the
second thing is the camera sensitivity
itself different cameras have a
different sensitivity to light and
you'll very quickly come to both
appreciate and hate some of the quirks
of our camera it is sensitive in
compared to some and not as others so it
depends on what you may be expecting you
can also however there there are
adjustments to cameras
and video cameras basically it's called
the gain control so the if the if the
light lighting situation is very poor
you don't have a lot of light the gain
can can be raised but the trade-off is
that the image gets very very fuzzy a
much lower resolution but there is that
sensitivity and then finally of course
there are lights you can add add light
either by changing the location going
from you know if this one room is too
dark and the next room isn't you can
change the rooms if you have lights you
can add them we actually RB if for this
class we're shooting available light for
the most part there will be one class on
lighting but we don't have lighting
packages that you're going to be
generally available but there are ways
to overcome that clip lights regular you
know sort of consumer lights and people
in this class have done interesting
things with those those kinds of things
in the past so anyway lots of ways to
control exposure the essential basic one
is the f-stop or aperture so let's go on
to focus the second F first thing to
know is that just like with exposure
this camera and almost all video cameras
have two settings auto and manual manual
focus is almost always preferred because
just as with exposure the auto setting
can be fooled it will breathe so you
know like it'll sort of change its mind
and focus on something else in the
middle of a shot which can be very
distracting and annoying so in almost
all situations you're gonna want to stay
manual both for f-stop and for focus but
you do have that option you do have auto
as a choice and there are situations you
know where it's better to be an auto
than to me and nothing right I mean if
if you grab the camera because you know
there's a flying saucer landing outside
and you want to get the shot if it's an
auto it's much better to have something
than to have nothing and you know to be
adjusting but generally we discourage
the use of auto focus and auto
iris second thing to think about with
focus is the depth of field depth of
field is basically a term that refers to
how much of your image in terms of the
depth is in focus so if you're shooting
me sitting here talking as our camera
person is hopefully I'm InFocus the
background behind me doesn't have to be
in focus and it might or might not be in
focus depending on the aperture that the
camera is set at so a very wide aperture
because it's a low-light situation means
that you have very shallow focus and the
background may be out of focus the the
smaller the aperture gets the deeper
your focus is so that the background so
that could become in focus and this is
something that you can it's an aesthetic
choice it's not just sort of determined
by your lighting although that's obvious
is something you have to deal with but
you can actually make choices about
what's in focus and what's not and how
deep the focus isn't in it and it has an
impact on how people read the images
that you create I don't know if anybody
here is nearsighted but if you want to
get a sense of how depth of field is
determined by the aperture you can take
your glasses off and you can actually do
this and the smaller you make the
pinhole that you're looking through the
more InFocus you are or that what you're
seeing is and it doesn't really work if
you're everything's always in focus for
you but for me it works really well so
if I don't have my glasses off in the
morning I can look at you and I can see
that you're quite sharp if I make the
pinhole small elephants it's so anyway
it's kind of a cool effect and it gives
you a sense that basically what's
happening is that the smaller the the
the the aperture that the light is
passing through the more aligned and
again I'm not this is not an optics
class and you know I'm not going to go
too far down this road that I don't know
much about but the the light is more is
more aligned there's less scatter and
that makes everything in sharper focus
so again focus is something that is
extremely important so as so as exposure
they're sort of non-negotiable
you know the first two F's are either
you did it or you didn't
you're either in focus or you're not and
you pretty much want to be in focus and
you pretty much want to be properly
exposed you don't want to have too much
light hitting your image you don't want
to have too little even if you want to
manipulate focus or exposure later
because you want to actually have things
appear out of focus it's much better to
do it in in editing and post-production
than to do it when you're shooting
because you can't change it back you
can't make a blurry image sharp you can
make a sharp image blurry you can take a
very well exposed image and make it dark
or bright but you can't very easily take
a dark image and make it properly
exposed so these first two as I said I
usually refer to them as the
non-negotiable to the next two however
are infinitely negotiable focal length
refers to whether you're shooting
something in a wide angle or a telephoto
or a normal setting and again you may
have you know it's an experience with
this with still photography wide-angle
ends are the the lenses that are a
smaller number of millimeters you know
like like the 12 million millimeter lens
the six millimeter lens you know the 16
millimeter lens telephoto are the big
numbers 200 300 150 and each of them
give you very very very different
feeling kinds of images the wide-angle
lens gives you a much wider angle of
view obviously so if you're filming
landscapes you could put a wide-angle
lens on your camera and from the same
position get a much wider field it also
gives you much deeper focus to go back
to the idea of depth of field with the
wide-angle lens it's much easier to get
everything in focus from the foreground
to the background telephoto lenses on
the on the other hand are a much
narrower angle of view so if I'm
standing in the same place
filming the same thing I'm seeing a much
narrower field
which can also be thought of as
magnification right so same image but
now if I'm filming the camera person is
filming me I'm seeing just his face
instead of the whole the whole field and
the focus the depth of field is much
shallower so it's much easier to get a
nice soft background on a telephoto lens
just one one other note about focal
length again it's it's something that is
infinitely variable and you can choose
as a filmmaker what kinds of focal
lengths you use but don't confuse a
wide-angle lens with a wide shot or a
telephoto lens with the close-up it's
easier to get a close-up with a
telephoto lens and it's easier to get a
wider shot with a wide-angle lens but
it's certainly possible to do a wide
shot with the telephoto lens you just
have to be much farther away from your
subject and vice versa it's much it's
very possible to do a close-up with a
wide-angle lens you just have to get
much closer but but they'll feel very
very different and I'll show you some
extreme examples in here in a minute
so this is an extreme wide-angle lens
what's what we call a fisheye lens and
you'll see you know first of all that
that it's very distorted but you're
seeing a very very wide field of view so
wide in fact that the only way to
accommodate is the distortion you're
also seeing incredible depth of field
the background the infinite distance is
is sharp and so is the hand that's not
that far away from thee from the camera
but also wide-angle lenses and this is
an extreme example wide-angle lenses
tend to distort and elongate the
distance between objects so that hand is
much closer to the camera than it might
appear and the distance between the hand
and and you know every other element
going back is somewhat elongated so it
makes small rooms to feel much bigger it
makes distances see much greater
telephoto lens would you know the long
lens because they're long do the
opposite so here we have a telephoto
shot of a bird and you see first of all
that the background is is very very soft
even though it's not that far be you
know really behind the bird
and things are very compressed so the
distance between the bird and the
background it feels like you know
there's not much distance at all even
though there might actually be quite a
lot one of the things about telephoto
lenses is that sometimes the the depth
of field is so shallow that you can
literally have you know like the eye of
the bird in focus and you know the the
background that you know the the plant
that it's standing on completely soft
here you the plant is actually InFocus
but if you're doing an interview like
the human eye might be in focus and
their ear might be out of focus yet at
an extreme telephoto lens so this is
actually you know aesthetically really
pleasing because the foreground jumps
out at you you know
our eye goes immediately to the bird and
the background just drops off into this
very soft nice kind of kind of backplate
so again I could shoot a wide shot like
this but it would look extremely
different than shooting a wide shot with
it with a wide-angle lens so now let's
talk about framing and framing this is
this is really you know once you sort of
master the basics of the camera framing
is kind of a catch-all term for sort of
everything else you know about how you
choose to shoot things you know do you
choose to shoot close-ups do you choose
to shoot wide shots what's the grammar
of film and we're not going to do any
kind of exhaustive talk about that right
now but it's an infinitely sort of
interesting and inexhaustible subject
Sabrina you mentioned you know that that
on Wednesday night when we were looking
at those very early films everything was
filmed head to toe
and that was because I mean there really
hadn't been a grammar a film developed
at that point they were just thinking
about them as stage plays so people
would walk in head to toe and they do
their thing and they'd walk out but you
know a few years after that people
started filming close-ups and that was a
huge revolution they started filming
shots of the hands
people doing things they started moving
the camera so that it would pan from one
person to another and back they started
filming shots with someone in the
foreground and someone in the background
and then they do a reverse with this
person in the foreground and this person
in the background and and that kind of
opened up this whole language that all
of us you know we're used to reading
this language because we've been doing
at our entire lives but at that point it
was extremely new you know what shot
works with this shot what's confusing
what's not confusing how do we
understand the scene and all of that is
is related to framing so we're going to
be looking at a lot of films in this
class we're going to be talking about
why they were shot the way they were
shot both in terms of the sort of the
social terms and the the technical terms
the technological terms but also in
terms of the framing and the grammar of
them and it's something that you're
going to gain a lot of experience and
understanding of as you as you make your
own films but just for starters
you know I'm going to talk a little bit
about just some basic kind of ideas and
concepts that you might want to think
about as as you as you frame a scene
let's take this class for instance how
would I film this class there are an
infinite number of ways that I could do
it it's being filmed right now for a
very particular reason a very particular
purpose OpenCourseWare is filming it and
the way they're filming it is by
focusing on me because I'm the one
talking and on the slides because it's
information that they're trying to
capture if we were filming it for other
purposes we could have a completely
different approach we could film it as a
documentary cinema verite direct cinema
style which is if you remember the the
scene the John F Kennedy documentary
about the primary in Wisconsin that we
watched the clip of on Wednesday night
that was all about the experience of
being there
and it had a very particular point of
view the experience of Jackie Kennedy
and JFK in that room shaking a million
hands being kind of pushed by the crowd
so if we were going to film this class
in that way we could use a handheld
camera that camera could be completely
mobile you know you could be beer you
know if I'm not what's important to the
filmmaker I could bear I might barely be
in it you know maybe it's a film about
you and they're following you in your
day and I'm just this sort of droning
voice in the background what they're
interested in is your response to the
environment and how to capture that so
it'd be a completely different a
completely different way of filming this
and the framing and that shot choices
would be completely different than what
we're doing right now we could film it
with multiple cameras we could film you
know as we did the other night we could
have a camera that you know plenty of
the students camera in the background we
could edit it together what how how we
you know how we shoot people whether we
shooting them in close-ups or wide shots
all has this really significant impact
on the story that we're telling and one
of the things with documentary film is
that you're you as a camera person like
again let's say that that we're doing
you know a day in the life of Sabrina as
the as the story unfolds we're
constantly making adjustments we're
constantly making new choices about what
to film so if we're filming your
experience of being in this class as
that experience changes as a camera
person you you would you know the camera
person would need to be sensitive to
that change so you know let's say you've
got an into a discussion and a
disagreement with Dave our TA you know
because you didn't agree with his
interpretation of something which will
happen not no one so suddenly we would
be focusing on Dave and your response to
Dave so you know we would be in
close-ups on you looked listening to
Dave looking unhappy arguing back
suddenly we're on Dave Dave is talking
back and forth back and forth and you
know me the in stride
who's being filmed right now I'm not
even in the picture it doesn't matter
what I what I'm saying or thinking or
doing you know that maybe then you know
where the camera person starts looking
for clothes reaction shots of other
students you know does everyone agree
with you or does everyone agree with
Dave and think you're wrong you know and
and as me and as you make that choice is
a camera person it's going to impact who
you choose to film so you know we went
we touched on the idea of fairness and
accuracy in the documentary film you
know what you choose to frame and how
you choose to frame it has a huge huge
impact on the story that you tell so you
can walk into that situation I just
described and film it with an agenda
like you know we want to make Sabrina
look like the smartest person in the
room so then you film it in a certain
way or you know we want to just we want
to show how you know how completely
isolated she is so it in a different way
or you could be very sensitive and open
to the the situation and adjust and try
to be making accurate or fair
representation of what's actually
happened and believe me that's that both
are common in in documentary film I'm
going in with an agenda is extremely
common and that's not the same as you
know lying quote/unquote manipulating
although there is an element of
manipulation to it but but generally we
do go in with preconceived notions and
it impacts how we how we frame things on
how we shoot things so anyway that's
kind of the overall thing we're not
going to talk about a lot of film
grammar right now because I could go on
for the rest of the time and I'd rather
get on to the actual camerawork but I am
going to I am going to just raise a
couple of things to think about since
you very soon have cameras in your hands
and you know just just basic kind of
kinds of things to think about as you
choose the shots that you that you're
going to
I'm gonna film first of all there's a
real tendency when you get a camera the
further you know for the first time and
I mean I'm you I'm sure everyone at this
point is filmed something you know with
a video camera there's a real tendency
to want to capture everything right so
we're we're in this room we're filming
and you sort of think like oh I'm gonna
get everything and you start doing this
which is basically moving continually
because that's how we our eyes work
right you know I'm I'm just looking
around I see everything so you just
assume the camera works that way too but
what you end up doing is capturing
nothing because with the camera you have
to you have to sort of fake the way your
eye works and the way your eye works is
I'm really I'm doing this I'm seeing
everything but I'm also continuously you
know my brain is continuously picking
out things and making close-ups out of
the stuff that I see making different
angles so when I was talking about you
suddenly there was a close-up of you
even though I saw everything else to
when I talked about Dave suddenly there
was a close-up of day in my head right
so the camera has to do that and you
have to make it do that which means that
you know what they call hosing down the
room which is this kind of continual
sort of well I don't want to you know I
don't want to miss anything so I'm just
gonna keep doing this it just ends up
with with mush and and you're not
telling a story and you're not really
getting any shots that you're able to
edit so you know you want to be
deliberate about what you're shooting
and you want to think about what you're
shooting you know what's the story am i
telling and what what images do I need
to tell that story you know do I need to
focus on on you do I need to focus on
Dave do I need to shoot a wide shot that
establishes the geography of the room so
that I know where people are sitting
second thing is very basic thing hold
your shots you know there's also a
tendency that goes along with this this
hosing down the room to never really
hold on anything so I'm filming Sabrina
but then suddenly I want to go over here
and then I want to go back and then
end up with nothing again so you you
know you want to want to make a choice
and then stick with it for long enough
that you actually get something so if
I'm shooting a close-up of Chris
listening to me
skeptically I want to hold on for an
absurd number of seconds and then go
back to the next thing that I want to
shoot and it can be hard sometimes
because you know suddenly something
really interesting is happening over
there and you want to run over and get
it and you need to be responsive to that
and obviously pay attention to it but if
you get sort of too caught up in the
moment you end up with nothing and and
this is something that is a real
struggle even for professional camera
people sometimes because they they have
all this sort of information bombarding
them about what they want to do and they
some of them especially people who come
from still photography maybe don't hold
the shots long enough you know there's
kind of a rule of you know like the nice
long slow count to ten
before you then pan away to something
else it could be a count to five the
action is a little faster but just
remember you know frame something up
hold the shot and then move on and then
you know the idea also when you're
moving the camera is is think about why
you're moving the camera why would you
move it why would you move the camera
rather than just to hose down the room
any basic ideas
well I know if I'm moving if I if I have
a camera
why would I actually start doing this
why would I actually move well compared
to compared to just moving like this
randomly or not moving at all
you know what would motivate me to move
the camera right yep exactly so
following an action and it might be an
actually a physical action I mean if I'm
if I'm profiling Chris and suddenly she
gets up and goes over and you know to
like you know really getting days face
to really argue with them I you know I'd
want to follow that right but if they're
just talking
even cordially I don't know why I always
bring you into conflict Dave yeah you
just draw you know you used try it out
of it but you know even if they're just
they're speaking as you say I would be
panning back and forth and at some point
I might come over here and film Dave and
start filming from his point of view so
that's the you know that's the situation
you try to we want to try to make your
moves motivated by something not just by
kind of random closing down of the room
so that's again just a really basic
concept and all of this is you know it's
going to make a lot more sense when you
start shooting and it's really going to
make sense when you start editing
because editing is the part where you
really learn how to shoot I think all
people who shoot should edit even if
they don't want to be editors because
that's when you really learned what's
working and what's not working in your
shooting a couple of other quick tips
remember that although film is a
two-dimensional art form and your images
are all 2d you're representing a 3d
world and that means that you want to
think about ways to create depth in your
frame which means essentially different
planes of action
so again if I'm filming Chris and Dave
if I come around like this and I shoot
Chris's shoulder in the foreground and
Dave in the Far background that's kind
of a nice deep shot because we're we got
a sense of the room we get a sense that
there's depth that there's kind of a
dimensionality to to the conversation
and then I can go over and I can do the
same this way you know I also might
still shoot close-ups and edited it all
together but you know what would be kind
of weird and disorienting would be is
again if they're having a conversation
and I just filmed a close-up of Chris
and then I went over and I filmed the
close-up of Dave and I never had any
sense of like the relationship in space
or what the room was like or anything
else because then you just have this
sort of head floating in space over here
head floating in space over there with
no kind of relationship between them and
no kind of three dimensionality so again
using depth of field using even if
something is out of focus in the
background or in the foreground you know
you you could also have the foreground
be out of focus so you know if I if
there was something on this computer
that was really really interesting and I
wanted to have Dave as well I could have
this be out of focus and Dave in focus
it doesn't have to be that the
foreground is the one the thing that's
in focus and then the last tip and then
I'm going to turn it over to Dave and
again I understand that this is all kind
of you know abstract at this point but
it's just kind of I want to put put some
ideas out there that will hopefully kind
of inform some of the shot choices that
you'll maybe making later but the last
thing I want to mention is framing in
terms of centering things or not
centering things we tend to think put
things off center this is an interview
that we did with Joel Dawson a professor
in electrical engineering here kind of
dark on the screen but you see that he's
off-center and there's a lot of negative
space on the left which is where he's
looking and that tends to be and I'm
talking about sort of very conventional
kinds of kinds of kinds of filming that
tends to be something that's a little
more pleasing because it gives this the
the frames more energy psychologically
I'm not exactly sure why that's true but
it might be that there's sort of space
for him to potentially move into rather
than being lined up right in the center
of the frame so there's so there he's
looking kind of into space that he could
sort of potentially occupy also just as
an aside notice that the background is
is very very soft it's shot with a quite
a long lens which is nice because you
know the interview subject pops out
number one and also number two it was
this very very unattractive lab and it
just goes away it's very nice the other
thing about about filling things off
center like this is that you you want to
think about in terms of framing and this
is getting kind of classic composition
think about your frame in thirds the the
the the third dividing lines you know if
you take a line and divide it vertically
in thirds and then there's one line
missing here but horizontally and thirds
the intersections of the lines tend to
be kind of powerful places in the frame
and you notice here again it's a very
kind of classic kind of framing his eye
lines up exactly with one of those third
places one of those intersections that's
why when you have close-ups of people in
movies and it gets really really close
they tend to chop the top of the head
off because they're keeping the eye line
roughly in the top third of the frame
you notice again he's centered this way
so there's a lot of negative space over
there you could just as easily put him
over here looking kind of this way into
the negative space and his eye could be
lined up with that if it was a wider
shot like a very wide shot maybe a head
to body shot and we saw the entire frame
you know you would probably if again if
it was classic classic framing his head
would end up being kind of in one of
these third spaces as well so you know
imagine a whole body with a head here or
here and if they were walking and you
were panning with them you know if he
was walking this way
you would probably frame him up kind
on that line with his head there which
would give him plenty of space to walk
into and then you would continue to pan
with him always giving more space here
which because again that gives you kind
of this energetic frame in the sense
that the person is walking and you're
following so that's the very very kind
of quick tour of some things to think
about when you frame and choose shots
and we will be spending a lot of time on
this in this in this class so don't
think that you know you needed to sort
of absorb it all right now but go ahead
yeah right right this will this will
make the most sense when you as I said
not only done some shooting but also
done some editing and you know between
now and then we will definitely be going
back to talk more about film language
and film grammar and the shot kinds of
shots that cut together and kinds of
shots that don't cut together I'm going
to turn it over to Dave in just a minute
but I want to say one last word about
formats so format's in video are
proliferating like crazy there are an
endless number of HD SD but at this
point primarily HD high definition
formats the one we're filming and are
using in this class is HD v 1080i 1440
by 1080 which is basically a compressed
version of Full HD which is 1920 by 1080
and you may know something about what
those things mean you may know nothing
about what they mean but I want you to
kind of write them down and you'll
absorb them later if that makes sense
basically 1920 by 1080 refers to the
size of the frame its 1920 pixels wide
by 1080 pixels high which again if we go
back to this frame that gives you
basically that aspect ratio so you know
it's wider than it is high
and that's you know sixteen by nine
televisions as opposed to standard
definition square or televisions our
data rate is 25 megabits per second and
that boils down to approximately more or
less 10 gigabits gigabytes per hour and
what that means obviously is that the
file sizes are very very large there's a
lot of data the cameras capturing a lot
of data the the computer you headed on
is expected to process a lot of data and
one of the things that we will be
talking about later in the class
is how you know the IT revolution has
really enabled video documentaries and
completely changed the game and enabled
things like this class to happen point
here is mainly just so that you're kind
of aware of the format that these
cameras shoot and what the file sizes
are going to be that's also why we give
each of your hard drive so that you
don't have to you know worry about how
you're going to store a terabyte worth
of material on your own so are any quick
questions before I turn it over to Dave
yeah
yeah it's basically squeezed but you
never see it squeeze the it actually
then gets uncompressed automatically
when it's viewed yes yeah you see the
same it looks like 1920 by 1080 and the
reason that they compress it like that
is to save safe space so the 25 megabits
per second data rate is very very low
for high definition you know video most
most data rates are higher than that
like 35 50 55 or 4 completely
uncompressed HD really I forget it's
really really high so so it's just a
strategy for for giving less data but
still having a nice HD image yeah you
never actually see that unless you make
a mistake in final cut which we can talk
about later and just one word about why
we're using tape in this era of cards
and files one reason is that the cameras
are a couple of years old but but
there's actually another reason to which
is that this provides a very cheap and
easy backup for you file management as
wonderful as cards are and as much as it
speeds the process and I'm a big fan of
them in a student situation if you want
to do cheap backups there's you know
tape this is great you can stick them in
your sock drawer and you're not have to
worry about your harddrive crashing into
something
you